de nombreux blessés hier soir au cours
de la contre manifestation qui était
organisée lors du meeting d'ordre
nouveau à la mutualité
c'est du côté des forces de l'ordre que
les blessés sont les plus nombreux plus
de 70 dont un serait très gravement
atteints commentaire de jean causait oui
malgré le quadrillage très serré on le
voit du quartier latin ce furent six
heures de violences autour du mythe
indoor blues tout comme un sont peu
avant 20 heures dimanche
une avant-garde de quelque 200
gauchistes ou manifestants antifascistes
ans précédents plusieurs centaines
attaque au cocktail molotov les barrages
des forces de police ou riposte
immédiate et très vive les heures
continueront jusqu'à minuit se
propageant vers le châtelet et jusqu'à
la bastille
[Applaudissements]
10dans 73 policiers blessés dont 16
hospitalisé un nombre elle est terminée
dans l'autre camp qui a emporté ses
blessés trois cars de police et
plusieurs voitures incendiées
durant ce temps avec des accessoires
peut-être moins voyante de coutume le
service d'ordre du mouvement ordre
nouveau fait du surplace à la mutualité
malgré les difficultés d'accès mille
personnes pour entendre le procès de
l'immigration sous toutes ses formes
économiques sanitaires politiques
nous avons commencé une vaste campagne
de pétitions immédiate de toute
immigration pendant un an
[Applaudissements]
des escarmouches sporadiques dont se
prolonger dans 13 pays né de l'amitié
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après minuit le service d'ordre du
meeting gagne son siège de la rue des
lombards attaqué quelques heures plus
tôt toutefois la porte blindée donnant
accès à la salle principale n'avait pas
cédé à la poussée des assaillants des
militants de garde auraient pu s'enfuir
du temps par les toits
jacques j